So we're going to talk
a little bit about Bohr.
And then we're going to talk
about ionization energy, which
is a theme that's going to
come back a couple more times.
Very important.
And then we're going quantum.
We're going quantum.
And that's why this is a
very exciting day for me.
And I'm hoping it
will be for you, too.
It's why I have t-shirts.
It's also a goody bag day.
There's just all sorts of
things happening today,
so I'm very excited.
This is how we ended our
lecture on Wednesday.
I was showing you this as part
of my why this matters, which
started with
refrigerators and then
we talked about a
chemistry problem, CFCs.
And we talked about how
those were destroying
the ozone layer of this planet.
Now, why is that important?
And I had this picture up
there to help explain it.
Just to make sure
we all see what
this is, I'm showing you here,
again, this is the energy--
watts per meter squared--
that we get from the sun.
And you can measure that up
on top of the atmosphere,
so there is no atmosphere there.
And this is what it looks like.
That's the energy as a function
of the wavelength or frequency,
or energy of the photon.
You now know how to go back
and forth between those.
But see, on the planet here,
once you have the atmosphere,
you get a different spectrum.
And the reason is--
and it's shown here--
that some of the molecules
in the atmosphere
are absorbing parts
of that spectrum.
So what we see on the
planet is different.
And we talked about this in
terms of why this matters
and how ozone--
so I mentioned, oh, if we
can only see out here--
the visible is here.
That's the visible.
There's the frequencies
of the visible.
But what if it were here?
The planet would
be totally dark,
because no light would get
through the absorption that
happens from those molecules.
On the other hand,
over here, we've
got ozone that's protecting us.
It is absorbing light
in the higher frequency,
which means lower wavelength.
That's the UV.
And that's why that was
such an important problem
is to not destroy those
precious ozone molecules.
So I wanted to make sure
that we-- and we understood
this in terms of
energy transition,
because how do these
things absorb light?
Well, they do just
what we said, which
is they take the energy
from a kind of light
and an electron then
takes that energy,
absorbs it to be excited,
and it goes from one energy
level to another.
And we did that in terms
of the Bohr levels,
so I wanted to do that.
And that is what
you have right here.
You have a way to see
that visible spectrum.
So we'll talk
about that as well.
Let's talk about it right now,
because have a slide on it.
So you have what is known as
a spectroscope, or the most
powerful way to see
light ever designed.
And if you look through this--
OK, don't look at the UV please.
Don't look at the sun.
Please don't do that.
But we gave you light
sources to look at.
Like that, right?
Or you can look at that.
Or you can look at things
around you with it.
And what are you seeing?
You're seeing this.
You're seeing the
spectrum in the visible.
You're seeing it in this part.
But from this, you are also--
what you are seeing are
literally electron transitions.
You are literally
seeing-- and that's
where I want you to think about.
That's why I wanted you to have
this power, this power, which
means responsibility,
as we know.
But now, you can
not only see light.
You can see electron
transitions.
I want you to think about
that as you're seeing light.
And I want you to think about
it in terms of what we learned
on Wednesday, which is Bohr.
And so let's just put that here.
So we had Bohr.
And in the Bohr model,
we said the energy
is going to be quantized
minus 13.6 electron volts
times the atomic number
squared divided by n squared.
And so for hydrogen,
for example, this
is equal to minus 13.6 ev,
because e is 1 over n squared.
So that was for
hydrogen. z equals 1.
And so that's it.
And that's it.
n is equal to 1,
2, 3, et cetera.
It's quantized.
This was the whole kind
of discussion and theme
of Wednesday's lecture.
And that got us to these
levels, these Bohr levels,
which are places where--
energetic places,
energies of the electron.
So we'd have these
levels that kept on going
until you're at somehow--
so this is energy.
And this would be like
n equals 1, n equals 2.
These are the
energies right there.
I'm just plugging in.
And this would be
n equals infinity,
so the energy here would be 0.
And for the hydrogen
atom, the energy
here would be minus
13.6 electron volts.
That's hydrogen. So this is--
now, I'm leaving this here
and I want to use this.
That's why I'm
putting it back up.
Because look, now
you can use this
to start understanding light.
And so you use this, and
you look at light sources,
and you can start
thinking about things
in terms of energy transition.
So let's take a look.
So what if I just look at
some light sources, all right?
OK, so that's what you see.
That's the sun, all right?
So that's daylight.
And now we're getting into
the mode of seeing light
like this, all right?
It's an intensity, salute
versus wavelength, right?
And there you go.
And now if you look at sort
of an incandescent light bulb,
it will look
something like this.
So it's warm.
There's a little
more red, all right?
You can't get up to
the sun's temperature,
but you can it pretty hot.
So you see this nice
kind of looking spectrum.
And, oh, here's a
halogen. All right,
that looks kind of closer maybe.
Look at what happens
when we go fluorescent.
Look at that.
Why does fluorescent
light give us headaches?
Well, that might
be other reasons.
But look at this spectrum.
That doesn't look like that.
That's why we all have so
much trouble with fluor--
and here's LEDs.
And you can buy your cool white
LEDs and your warm white LEDs.
But look, they're still not.
They're not that, right?
There's been a lot
of work on this.
Can we get this to
be that, all right?
And so now we are
armed with great power.
And so you can look at things.
You can say, oh,
I see that it has
this large peak because I'm
looking at a fluorescent light
within it.
And I see that it's got this
stronger peak in the blue.
Maybe I could just
absorb a little of that.
What if I came up
with a coating,
all right, that I could
put on that cool LED bulb
to make it just a little
bit more look like that?
Well, now we know
how to we might
be able to use a board
to do this, all right?
Because what if-- so let's
say, OK, the wavelength of that
is around 450.
So if the wavelength is 450
nanometers, then I know--
remember we did this--
waves, light waves,
we can go back and forth
between frequency--
hello.
How's it going?
All right, welcome to class.
And energy, energy
equals hc over lambda.
Oh, Planck, thank you.
And this is roughly
2.75 electron volts
for that wavelength 2.75
electron volts, right?
OK, well, but see
now you say, but I
want to absorb some
of those photons.
I'll pose a problem.
What if I have an atom--
so question, right?
So I have an atom,
an atom that has
an n equal 4 to n equal 5
transition that absorbs.
So I'm telling you
now this energy.
So I'm telling you now
I've got some atom,
and I know there's
a transition in it.
It has an electron transition.
Because remember, we're going
from electron transitions
to light energy, back and
forth, back and forth.
Look at this right here.
I'm just saying, look,
OK, n equals-- just
keep going. n equals 3,
n equals 4, n equals 5.
So what I just asked
you is, I said.
Well look, some atom has
a transition between n
equals 4 and n equals 5.
That means that if an
electron happens to be here,
it can absorb energy
to promote it up
to here of exactly 2.75 vb.
Uh-huh, well, I can use Bohr.
I can use Bohr now, right?
Because so I can actually
answer this problem,
answer this question.
If I know that, then
I can say, well, OK,
if the initial state is 4, and
the final state is 5, right--
I've gone from 4 to 5.
I've promoted an electron
up in energy, lifting it up
like a ball against
gravity, all right?
Then if then I can
use Bohr to say
that 2.75 eV is equal to minus
13.6 z squared times 1 over 5
squared minus 1
over 4 squared, that
would be the transition
energy, this, dictated by Bohr.
And, oh, I have
everything except z,
which I can solve for.
z equals 3.
z equals 3, OK?
So now all I need
to do is come up
with a way to code all the
cool LEDs with lithium, right?
Because this is lithium.
And we'll be fine,
except there's a problem.
And this is part of
the problem that we
need to address and solve
today before the weekend.
And that is that, see, Bohr
only works for one electron.
Now, it's OK. z can be higher.
z is 3, and it works here.
But I assumed only one electron,
which means this really
would be like li 2 plus.
Oh, OK, we're going
to come back to that.
But Bohr only for one
electron, all right?
So if I'm going to get something
like z is 3, that's fine.
But it can only have
one electron there.
It can only have one
electron there or the model
doesn't work.
It was one electron with
some z of protons, all right?
So this could be li 2 plus.
That sounds harder to
put into a film, OK?
We will be coming back to this.
That is a serious limitation
of the Bohr model.
And we can't do a lot if we can
only do one electron, right?
You can do a lot of
ions, but that's it.
OK, so I just said the word ion.
What happens now if you take an
electron not from one level up
in energy, but up, up,
up, up, up, all the way
until it's free?
What happens if you do that?
Well, that is called ionization.
That's ionization.
And, in fact, when you look
out into the beautiful world,
the universe--
remember I said on
Wednesday, 75% of this
is hydrogen. A whole
lot of it is ionized.
It's getting ionized from energy
that's knocking electrons out.
And then electrons
are coming back
and cascading
through these levels,
emitting discrete
frequencies of light.
And this is what you see.
It's beautiful, right?
And what you're looking
at is ionized hydrogen
getting electrons coming in
and cascading through the Bohr
levels, all right?
Ah, but what does ionized
hydrogen mean, right?
OK, we can now understand it.
We can now understand
it because now,
instead of going
from 4 to 5, I'm
going from anything to infinity.
It's like escape
velocity, right?
It's like, how much velocity
do I need to give something?
So it just gets
away from the earth.
And it's not going to feel the
earth's gravitational pull.
Well, here, I don't
want this electron
to feel the potential
of the atom anymore,
the z, the positive charge.
I want it to just be free.
That's here.
That's infinity.
That's n equals
infinity, all right?
So if I think about this,
that's actually quite easy
to put into Bohr,
ionization energy.
So to save time,
we'll write IE, right?
And this is equal to the
energy required-- oh, I'm
going to save time here.
Look at that-- req'd to remove
the electron from the atom.
OK, good.
And if we think about
this in terms of Bohr,
it would be minus 13.6--
let's say for hydrogen, because
I've got hydrogen up there.
So for hydrogen,
meaning z equals 1,
it would be minus
13.6 times 1 squared--
that's the z
squared, all right--
times 1 over nf squared
minus 1 over ni squared.
That's that delta
e, which equals
minus 13.6 times 1 over
infinity minus 1 over ni
squared, all right?
And the last I checked
with my colleagues
in the math
department, that's 0.
That's 0, all right?
So the ionization
energy, you literally
can just read off here.
If an electron is
in the ground state,
if there's a happy electron
right here in this orbital,
the amount of energy I need
to input into that atom
to knock the electron fully
out, the ionization energy,
is 13.6 electron volts, right?
It's just the energy
of that orbital.
I can get a little
fancier and say, well, OK,
what about this question.
What if I had light
with 100 nanometers?
So now I'm telling you
my source, all right?
Before I didn't tell you.
Say something goes into
it and knocks it all out?
No, now I know what's going in.
The wavelength, or the energy of
the photons, is 100 nanometers.
And I'm shining
that on hydrogen.
Well, now, OK, let's see here.
So a little example.
Oh, I'm asking a question.
What's the question?
What is the lowest energy
level that the electron could
be in such that a photon
from this light source
ionizes the atom?
OK, let's see, because
I now know the pieces,
and I know the
definition, all right?
So now if I have the energy
of 100 nanometer photon,
well, that--
I'm not going to go through it--
is equal to 12.4 eV.
Uh-huh.
But see, if I now want to
use this to ionize hydrogen,
then I get something like this.
I get the delta E
equals minus 13.6 times
1 oer infinity squared--
OK, fine, we'll keep
that for a sec--
minus 1 over ni squared, right?
This is how much.
This is how much
delta I need to ionize
from any given place, any given
energy level ni, all right?
OK?
But I have 12.
So what if I set this
equal to 12, all right?
If I set this equal to
12.4, that's what I have.
Then what I get
is ni equals 1.05.
OK, good, that's my answer.
No.
Panic.
Everybody should be panicking.
No.
That can't be my answer.
I can't have--
I can't have something
that's not an integer,
because I said it over there
that n is a quantum number.
1, 2, 3, nothing is
allowed in between.
Mm-mm.
So what you can see is
that I got so close.
I almost had enough
energy to get n to be 1.
But I don't.
So I cannot use this light to
ionize an electron in n equals
1.
I can't.
But I could use it to ionize an
electron in n equals 2, right?
Because there, if n
is 2, well, then I've
got actually plenty
of energy, all right?
So cannot ionize from ni equals
1, but ni equals 2 is OK,
all right?
So that's the outcome of this.
Now, I could also use that same
12.4 eV photon to ionize from n
equals 3, or 4, or any of these.
But I can't get to 1.
And there's one other
concept that's important.
Because look, I gave it 12.4 eV.
What did I actually need?
Well, you can even see it here.
You know what these levels
are from the Bohr model.
Here, this is 13.6.
This is minus 3.4, OK?
That's telling me this is
definitely not drawn to scale.
But still, you get
the point, 3.4.
And I just said, well, I could
probably get it out of 3.4.
And I can because I've got 12.4.
And so if I did this--
so if ni equals 2, then I
would have excess energy.
Excess energy would be
nine electron volts.
And that is kinetic, right?
So I've shot this thing
out of the atom with light
that's got way more energy
than I needed to ionize it.
But that energy, it's
still in the electron.
I transferred that photon
energy to the electron energy.
And so that is going to
be in the kinetic energy
of the electron that's now
free, the electron free.
I should have said
free electron, right?
Excess kinetic energy comes
after ionizing, right?
So these things are the
things we can do with Bohr.
So I wanted to kind of take
what we learned Wednesday
and apply it to a few
problems and go back and forth
with this idea of photon
energy to Bohr level changes.
And that's what I want you to
do in this week's goody bag
as well.
OK, now ionization is
an important concept.
Like I said, we'll
be coming back to it.
And you can actually plot--
and many people have measured,
and this is very important-- the
ionization energy of elements,
like as a function
of atomic number.
And the first ionization
energy is important, right?
The first line
ionization energy is
the energy required to remove
the outermost electron, right?
All right, so if I did have
a whole bunch of electrons,
so if I had a whole
bunch of electrons.
the first ionization, the
first ionization energy
is the energy required to
remove the outermost one.
So that's an important
number to know.
If you want to take an
electron off of an atom--
and will be doing
that because that's
how we're going to make
our first bond next week--
if you want to take an
electron off an atom,
this is one of the
first things you ask.
How much energy does
it take, all right?
How much energy does it take?
So that's an important concept
that we'll be coming back to.
Now, OK, I alluded to the fact
that we needed a new theory.
I already alluded to that.
And I said that's where
we're going today.
The Bohr model works for
one electron, as I said.
All right, that means it's
good for hydrogen. Oh, we just
ionized hydrogen, and
that was a lot of fun.
And it's good for He plus, or
Li2 plus, or osmium 75 plus.
Yeah, that's real.
But what about two electrons?
What about two, just two?
Forget about 10, 20, 30.
2, the Bohr model can't do it.
It doesn't.
It doesn't work for anything
more than one electron.
It was derived for one electron,
and that's where it stays.
So we're at this point now.
This is the picture I started
to draw this week on Monday.
And we're at a point where
we need something deeper.
And some of the work that went
into this was really critical.
And I'm not going to go
into too much detail,
but there's one thing
I want you to know.
So remember, Planck
and Einstein,
they were playing with
quantization of light.
And Einstein's photoelectric
effect found the particle
nature of light, with Planck's--
you know, with together,
their energy, equals h nu, that
quantized energy of the photon.
And they saw it was a
particle, but it also
was a wave, all right?
There's a lot of
discussion, and interest,
and attempt to
understand what it was.
Was it a wave or a particle?
And Compton did some
beautiful experiments
to show, again,
evidence that it was
a particle because
he saw how light
interacted with electrons.
And it was like this
collision that particles do.
And then De Broglie,
or as [INAUDIBLE]..
De Bro-- I don't know--
would say he went further.
De Broglie went further.
He said, everything is both.
Light, you guys don't know if
light is a particle or a wave.
Well, I'm saying everything
is a wave, everything.
And everything has this duality.
So he wrote something
very important,
which is the relationship
between anything's momentum
and its wavelength.
So we'll come back to this.
So I want to write it down.
So De Brog-- he said that
the wavelength of anything
can be written as, oh,
that same quantization
number, constant from Planck
divided by its momentum,
literally, just its momentum.
Anything has a wave
nature, anything.
And light has a particle nature.
What's going on?
And it led Einstein
to say at the time--
he said, quote, "It seems as
though we must use sometimes
the one theory and sometimes
the other while at times
we may use either.
We are faced with a
new kind of difficulty.
We have two contradictory
pictures of reality.
Separately, neither
of them fully
explains the phenomena of light.
But together, they do.
This was the beginning
of quantum mechanics.
This is where they were.
And later, once they really
got the quantum mechanics
kind of going, he said this.
The more success the
quantum mechanics
has, the sillier it looks.
Why?
Well, there's only one way to
really learn about quantum,
especially if it's
the first time.
And that's from Dr.
Quantum himself.
And so I do have a
video of Dr. Quantum.
And I'm hoping you will
enjoy this with me.
I enjoy it every time I
see it, most Friday nights.
So let's watch Dr.
Quantum explain.
Because there was one really
important experiment that
happened that he's going
to explain right now
called the double
slit experiment.
And it changed everything.
And I don't care if you
see it in another class.
We're seeing it here
because this sets up
what happens next in chemistry.
Let's watch Dr. Quantum.
--are.
The granddaddy of all
quantum weirdness,
the infamous double
slit experiment.
To understand this
experiment, we first
need to see how particles, or
little balls of matter act.
If we randomly shoot
a small object,
say a small marble
at the screen,
we see a pattern
on the back wall
where they went through
the slit and hit.
Now, if we add a
second slit, we would
expect to see a second band
duplicated to the right.
Now, let's look at waves.
The waves hit the
slit and radiate out,
striking the back wall
with the most intensity
directly in line with the slit.
The line of brightness
on the back screen
shows that intensity.
This is similar to the
line the marbles make.
But when we add the second slit,
something different happens.
If the top of one wave meets
the bottom of another wave,
they cancel each other out.
So now there is an interference
pattern on the back wall.
Places where the two tops meet
are the highest intensity,
the bright lines.
And where they cancel,
there is nothing.
So when we throw things, that
is matter, through two slits,
we get this, two bands of hits.
And with waves, we get
an interference pattern
of many bands.
Good so far.
Now, let's go quantum.
It's my favorite line.
I love that line.
An electron is a tiny, tiny bit
of matter, like a tiny marble.
Let's fire a stream
through one slit.
It behaves just like the
marble, a single band.
So if we shoot these tiny
bits through two slits,
we should get, like
the marbles, two bands.
What?
An interference pattern.
We fired electrons, tiny
bits of matter through.
But we get a pattern like
waves, not like little marbles.
How?
How could pieces of matter
create an interference pattern
like a wave?
It doesn't make sense.
But physicists are clever.
They thought, maybe
those little balls
are bouncing off each other
and creating that pattern.
So they decide to shoot
electrons through one
at a time.
There is no way they could
interfere with each other.
But after an hour of this,
the same interference pattern
seemed to emerge.
The conclusion is inescapable.
The single electron
leaves as a particle,
becomes a wave of potentials,
goes through both slits,
and interferes with itself to
hit the wall like a particle.
But mathematically,
it's even stranger.
It goes through both slits,
and it goes through either,
and it goes through
just once, and it
goes through just the other.
All of these possibilities
are in superposition
with each other.
But physicists were
completely baffled by this.
So they decided to
peek and see which
slit it actually goes through.
They put a measuring
device by one slit
to see which one it went
through, and let it fly.
But the quantum world
is far more mysterious
than they could have imagined.
When they observed,
the electron went back
to behaving like
a little marble.
It produced a pattern of two
bans, not an interference
pattern of many.
The very act of
measuring, or observing
which slit it went
through meant it only
went through one, not both.
The electron decided to act
differently as though it
was aware it was being watched.
And it was here that
physicists stepped forever
into the strange neverworld
of quantum events.
What is matter,
marbles or waves?
And waves of what?
And what does an observer
have to do with any of this?
The observer collapsed the wave
function simply by observing.
You can see why I show this.
We do movie night at home a lot.
It's Friday night, guys.
Seriously, you know that you
might have a little free time.
You get together
with some friends.
There's no better way.
But look, this is why--
I hope that's as mindblowing
to you as it is to me.
It was mindblowing
to them at the time.
This led Bohr to
famously say, anyone
who is not shocked by quantum
theory has not understood it.
And here's the thing.
There are some things in life
where you can ask questions,
and you can understand them.
You can answer them.
I can ask the question
why do-- or somebody
might say, why do I wear a
t-shirt under a sportcoat?
That's weird, stylistically.
I mean, stylistically, that's--
and I say, well, OK,
here's the answer.
Because I put comfort
over stylistic norms.
Whatever, that's an answer.
I could ask a harder question.
Why did Justin and
Selena break up?
Because Jalina was totally
hashtag couple goals.
Just saying.
OK, anyway, now I'm just--
why?
Oh, but still that's
a harder question.
Why?
Because they were so good.
But there's probably
an answer to that too.
That's a harder question.
This was mindblowing.
How can something be both?
How can something that
they know is a part of--
How can everything be both?
This was really
difficult to answer.
And, in fact, the
real answer came
with a mathematical solution,
which we'll learn next, but not
quite understanding.
We still don't really
understand quantum mechanics,
even after 100 years.
We don't.
And so this is just, I think,
a beautiful part of our story,
of our detective story.
And just to show, people are
still working on this, right?
How much quantum can we see?
Well, look, here's somebody
who, about 15 years ago--
and it's published
in this paper--
and a little more,
almost 20 now.
They actually took--
forget about electrons.
Those are teeny, tiny things.
This is a whole group
of 60 carbon atoms.
That's called the fullerene.
And they shot this through--
they did the double slit
experiment with this.
And they showed that
with the grading--
wait, without, you get the
signal peak, just like we saw.
And with you get interference.
You get interference.
So they were able to
show all the way up
to a large molecule,
60 carbon atoms,
that these things are
still-- they have wavelength.
They have these incredibly
strange properties
that you just saw in the
double slit experiment.
All, everything has this
duality, this duality
between waves and particles.
Now, OK, so we needed
a new model, right?
Bohr can only do one electron.
And meanwhile, there's all
this stuff going on at the time
showing that you
need a new theory.
How do we explain waves?
And to kind of put
a little bit more
of the nail in the coffin
for Bohr, you had Heisenberg.
So I'm just going to
write this on the board
before I go into
why this matters.
And what Heisenberg said is
that you cannot measure both
position and momentum exactly.
You can't get them both, OK?
And that's called the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle.
But that was it, because--
look, you look at that
and you say, well,
he-- saying this.
But in Bohr, you got them both.
You've got them both exactly.
Remember, I put
energy down there.
But we also put r on
Wednesday, exactly.
Gesundheit.
You can't get them both.
And if you can't get
them both, that's
another problem with
Bohr because Bohr
says you can get
them exactly, right?
So we had these pointers,
double slit experiment,
Heisenberg's
theories, all right,
saying we need something more.
We need something more.
And I'll get to that.
I want to do my
why this matters.
And then I'll get to the more
that came, which we'll then
expand on Monday.
Before I do that, let's
do why this matters.
So why is the fact that
an electron is a wave,
why is that so important?
Well, first of all, because
it sets up this detective
story of the electron set up
this new theory that's coming,
quantum mechanics, right?
But also, it immediately, just
like we started painting with
them, right-- remember that was
one of my why this matters--
we also realized that
we could see with them.
We could see with electrons.
Because if electrons
are waves, then
I can shine them just
like I shine light
and see what it shows me, right?
It can illuminate matter.
So if you look at the
frequency here of light,
this is an electromagnetic
spectrum-- radio, microwave,
infrared, visible, UV.
Now, here's the thing.
If you want to see
something, some feature size,
you're limited by the
wavelength of the light.
It can't be bigger than the
features you're looking at,
roughlyish, OK?
That's what you'll-- so if
you're trying to see something
tiny, but the wavelength
of light is really big,
you won't see it.
So we need-- let's say
we want to see atoms.
Let's say we want to see
atoms, or even more, nuclei.
Look at how tiny.
Those are 10 to the minus n,
10 to the minus 12 meters.
Those are x-rays or gamma rays.
But the problem is, if we
shine x-rays on things--
and we will do that when
we look at crystals--
but if we shine
x-rays, it's very hard
to then collect them and
make a photographic image,
OK, at least one that
gets you that resolution.
And gamma rays are even
harder to catch, all right?
But see, here's the thing.
The electrons give you
exactly what you need.
Because if we do this
math for an electron--
so bring this one back down--
if we do this math
for an electron,
well, I'm going to use--
oh, I thought I
had the middle one.
So if I have an electron-- let's
suppose I have an electron that
is--
electron, I'm going to say I
accelerate it over 100 volts.
I'm going to take
an electron, and I'm
going to put it over 100 volts.
I'm going to give it some
kinetic energy, right?
So it's kinetic energy is then
going to equal 100 eV, right?
OK, so now I've got an electron
moving with a kinetic energy
that's 100 eV.
Now you can convert
this to joules,
and you can set this equal
to 1/2 mv squared, right,
mass of the electron times
its velocity squared.
And then once you have the
velocity, so you get the V.
And then once you have that, you
get the momentum, the p, right?
And then once you have that,
you get the wavelength, right?
So I can go now from
something that's easy to do.
100 volts is a lot, but in a
lab safe, not in your dorm.
You could apply 100
volts to an electron,
get it going at this speed.
And once you know the speed,
you know the momentum.
And if you know mv, then
you know it's wavelength.
In that case from
this relationship,
you would get that it's
about 0.12 nanometers.
But look at this.
The wavelength of a simply
accelerated electron
is right where I need it.
It's right where I need it.
It's an Angstrom, right?
So now, if I take advantage
of the wavelengths of the wave
nature of electrons and I
shine them on materials,
then I can see
materials that way.
And I can see them
at that scale.
And we do that all
the time, all the time
in many, many different areas of
technology and research today.
We use electrons to image.
In fact, the best
images you can get
are made with
electrons, all right?
Here's an example
of using what's
called a scanning electron
microscope, all right?
So you see a butterfly, but you
want to really see a butterfly,
or we can go even further.
And instead of just
drawing pictures
of this these beautiful
materials made of carbon--
those are called nanotubes.
This is called graphene.
Gesundheit.
It's a single sheet of carbon
atoms, one atom thick material.
Notice with these
materials every single atom
is a surface atom.
That's pretty cool.
They also have lots of
other cool properties.
And I'll give you examples
throughout other lectures
of how these kinds of
materials can be used.
But for now, I'm talking
about seeing them.
And this is what happens
when you actually
look at them with an electron.
That's a nanotube.
And here is a
picture of graphene.
The only reason we
can see graphene
is because we have electrons.
And we take advantage of the
wave nature of those electrons.
Well, you say, well, OK.
But why does that matter?
Well, that matters
tremendously, because one
of the first experiments that
really did what Feynman, what
Richard Feynman wanted--
Richard Feynman predicted
the field of nanotechnology
50 years ago.
He gave a famous
speech at Caltex
called There's Plenty
of Room at the Bottom.
He's also an amazing teacher,
and he taught actually
the double slit experiment.
I highly recommend you
Googling that lecture.
And he said that someday,
you can put the atom
where you want, all right?
And the first time that was
done was in 1989 by IBM.
They had 35 xenon atoms.
They moved them around.
But the point is, you couldn't
realize nanotechnology.
You couldn't realize the
ability to actually move atoms
if you can't see them, right?
And this, the ability to
see what you were doing
changed everything.
It changed everything.
And nature had been doing this.
And I love these examples.
So nature has been doing
nanotech for a long time,
all right?
So you have the inner
ear of the frog.
It's a cantilever that is
sensitive to a few nanometers
of movement.
The frog can actually hear that.
You've got features
in the ant's eye.
I love the silk moth.
The male silk moth has a single
molecule detection system
onboard that can sense a
single molecule pheromone.
It can detect a female silk moth
two miles away, two miles away.
We have nothing like that.
We have no
technologies like that.
I can't even tell if
someone's in the next room.
I have to look at my
phone or something.
This is because of
nanotechnology, that kind
of detection system, all right?
But it was the ability to
see atoms and molecules
with electrons that
kind of blew open
this entire field, all right?
And it's made it
so that we can now
try at least to rival nature.
Here is one example.
You're not just seeing
graphene, but check this out.
You're seeing a single
atom of graphene,
and you're seeing what
happens under a certain kind
of irradiation.
And you're seeing this hole.
And you're seeing the hole grow.
And that's really
important, because something
I care a lot about
are membranes, right?
And another one of
these matters, I'll
tell you about membranes.
But here, I'm actually making
the thinnest possible membrane
that you could make because
it's only one atom thick.
And I'm controlling
how I make that.
But I would never know what
my controls do if I couldn't
see it in real time, all right?
So this is my why this matters.
It's seeing things
at this scale.
OK, so back to-- so
there's Heisenberg, right?
So in every moment, the electron
is only inaccurate position
and an accurate velocity.
This was, again, saying Bohr,
you got to think harder.
And we had all of
these experiments
showing the particle wave
duality of nature and of atoms.
And so the question
then became--
all these pointers from
all these different places,
the question became,
how do we describe
this wave nature of matter?
How do we describe an
electron as a wave?
And I like this,
because not only
do I think if Schrodinger had
a swimming pool this is what he
would do with it, but
also I thought maybe
this would be cool for
an MIT kind of swim test
thing in the future.
Because you can
see what happens.
This, I want to do
this experiment.
But this looks really fun.
They're making waves.
They're literally
making waves, right?
And so the question
now-- look at that.
See, but the question is,
how do you describe it?
Well, there are wave equations.
There are wave
equations that we know
about that relate the position
of a wave to it's time change
in velocity, all right?
And the thing is, this is it.
This is how we need to
describe an electron.
Now, think about
it for a second.
An electron-- by
the way, it just
occurred to me that you should
take this on that same day.
Because if they don't
have real candles,
and they only have these,
you should have this handy
because you might need to pull
it out and see what kind of LED
they gave you.
What does it look like?
Anyway, OK, that
was a side point.
Bohr says electrons can
only be in certain places.
Well, that's
mindblowing because--
by the way, think about that.
An electron can only
be here or here.
Oh, and by the way, it can
transition between them,
but it never be between them.
Did anyone catch that?
What's up with that?
It can't be between them.
I am telling you that.
But it can transition.
Where did it go?
Oh, OK, that's a weekend
kind of exercise.
And now we're saying they're
not even in one place.
They're waves.
They're like the water.
That's cra-- that really was
at the time-- they thought
how is this possible, right?
But Schrodinger came along.
And he said, I'm going to
write down the equation anyway.
And that was the
big contribution,
the really critical contribution
that Schrodinger did, is he
said, I'm going to write
down kind of like a Newton's
equation, like nf equals ma,
but for quantum mechanics
and for waves, like electrons.
And I'm going to describe them.
So he developed the
equation that we
saw, that on Monday we'll
solve, to describe the wave
nature of quantum mechanics.
And just to end--
so on Monday we'll pick up
with Schrodinger's equation
for the atom.
The question is, what does
this all mean for chemistry?
What does this mean?
We're not-- I'm not
teaching you quantum.
I'm not teaching you
quantum just so you
know quantum in isolation.
I'm telling you about
it because it completely
revolutionized chemistry.
And that is where we will
answer that question on Monday.
Have a really good weekend.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]